Well, it was bound to happen eventually: the
Rise of Skywalker rumor mill has finally churned
out a genuine gut punch.
Reddit user JediPaxis, who claims to be close
to the film's production, has been busily
leaking what they claim to be the entire plot
of the film over the last month or so.
Their latest revelation has to do with C-3PO,
and, if it's got any truth to it, it seems
that more than a few fans' hearts are going
to be broken into pieces.
Of course, it's important to point out that
this report has been in no way confirmed.
The rumors around The Rise of Skywalker have
been flying fast and furious of late, and
nothing substantial has come from any official
sources that back up JediPaxis' leaks.
That said, the reports offered up by JediPaxis
carry an air of legitimacy for one compelling
reason: several of the plot points which they
have put forward have been verified by Star
Wars fan sites, who each cite their own independent
sources.
Bespin Bulletin and Jason Ward of MakingStarWars.com
have both corroborated specific elements of
JediPaxis' reports — so there's a good chance
some of these leaks contain at least some
accurate information.
It should also be mentioned that The Rise
of Skywalker is currently in the midst of
reshoots, so some of the plot details that
are being reported on at this time could easily
change by the time the final cut hits theaters.
Having said all of that, do be aware: potentially
huge spoilers for The Rise of Skywalker lay
ahead.
This particular rumor revolves around a mysterious
dagger which was once owned by a Force user
loyal to the Sith, and upon it is inscribed
a message in an unidentifiable language.
During the course of the film, Rey, Poe, and
Finn are led to believe that this dagger may
be the key to locating a Wayfinder, a device
that for plot reasons is desperately sought
after by both the movie's heroes and villains.
Putting a long story short: it has a lot to
do with this guy right here.
Luckily, the heroes are able to locate the
dagger, but C-3PO despite being fluent in
over six million forms of communication can
only identify the inscription as an ancient
Sith language, one which he cannot translate
due to restrictions in his programming.
Finn, Rey and Poe subsequently enlist the
aid of an old acquaintance of Poe's named
Zorri Bliss to track down someone capable
of hacking the protocol droid's programming,
thus allowing him to provide a translation.
They're able to do so, but there's a catch.
And it's a pretty significant catch, too.
Zorri's contact informs Rey, Poe, and Finn
that he can get them what they want but if
he does, C-3PO's memory will be completely
wiped.
Understandably, the heroes are reluctant to
lose their faithful companion, but this is
where C-3PO finally gets his moment in the
spotlight.
The droid insists that the procedure be carried
out, knowing full well that, for all intents
and purposes, it will lead to his death.
Zorri's contact does his thing, and the modification
results in a new, red-eyed look for 3PO, as
seen in the D23 trailer that debuted earlier
this year.
The droid is then able to read the dagger's
inscription, which reveals the location of
the Wayfinder.
Once his task is complete, C-3PO reboots — and
after that happens, he's no longer the droid
he once was, instead now little more than
a blank slate.
It's worth noting that C-3PO has appeared
in every single Star Wars film save for Solo:
A Star Wars Story.
It's also safe to say that he's been more
prone to cowardice than heroism during that
time.
But if The Rise of Skywalker is to be the
character's last on-screen appearance, which
it almost certainly is, it seems apt to finally
give this iconic protocol droid a genuine
moment of heroic self-sacrifice.
"I never knew I had it in me."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.